موجز الاخبار اهلا بكم قالت المصادر
ودبلوماسيه الاتحاد الاوروبي اقر الحزمه
التاسعه من العقوبات على روسيا وكلفاء
القاده الاوروبيين خلال قمه بروكس الوزراء
الطاقه بالتواصل الى توافق بشان تحديد سقف
اليسار الغاز في اجتماعي من المقبل يوم
الاثنين
من حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ستكون حاسمه
المقابل قال الرئيس الروسي الذي ميرفت
امين
عدوان غير مسبوق لتقويه اقتصادي بلاده
وتدمير الروبل الروسي وشدد بوتن على ان
تلك المساعيد لم تفلح
قال الجيش الاوكرانيين القوات الروسيه
قصفت البنيه التحتيه في مقاطعه اخر كيف
صواريخ اس 300 لاستهداف في البنيه التحتيه
الشرقيه البلاد اضفنا القوات الروسيه وصلت
قصه مقاطعه جنوبيه وشرقيه البلاد
الروسيه من عواقب تورط الولايات المتحده
في الحرب بشكل مباشر فقالتنا جميع الاسلحه
المرسله لاوكرانيا من الغرب اهداف
المشروعه للجيش الروسي وكان مسؤولون
امريكي
يوصل النقيبون التونسيون في المهجر
الادلابي اصواتهم في الانتخابات التشريعيه
وجددت جبهه الخلاص الوطنيه دعوه الى
مقاطعه الانتخابات قائله ان حل الازمه
يكمن في حوار وطني شامل وقالت حركه النهضه
ان الانتخابات تهدف لتمكين مواصفات
بانقلاب من الانفراد بالسلطه في غضون ذلك
قرر البرلمان الاوروبي عدم ارسال بعثه
لمراقبه الانتخابات التونسيه بينما رفض
الرئيس سعيد الانتقادات الامريكيه لتوسيع
صلاحيته
طلعت احتجاجاتهم في عدد من المدن الاردنيه
بتزامني مع الاضراب الذي نفذه سائق
الشاحنات وعاملون في قطاع النقل والشحن
احتجاجا على رفع اسعار المحروقات وقال
جهاز الامن العام من ضابطا برتبه عقيد قتل
وصبا خران بعيار ناريا نطلقه من وصفه
بالمخربين في مدينه الحسينيه بمحافظه معان
وحذرت السفاره الامريكيه في الاردن رايها
من السفر الى مدن جنوب الاردن حتى اشعار
اخر
قررت المحكمه العليا في بيروت تمديد
احتجاز الرئيس المعزول بترو كاستيو لمده
18 شهرا على خلفيه اتهامه بالتامر والتمرد
وفادت وكاله الصحافه الفرنسيه بمقتل سبعه
اشخاص في جنوب البلاد خلال تجدد
الاحتجاجات على عزل كاسترو
[موسيقى]